on the next segment of where the
Avengers are currently at in the MCU we
will be talking about the Hulk and Bruce
Banner in the Avengers age of Ultron
Hulk leaves the Avengers flying away and
we don't find out till thor ragnarok
that he ends up on the planet Sekar also
if you haven't seen Thor Ragnarok
there's some spoilers coming your way we
also find out that he has been the Hulk
for two years meaning that he hasn't
turned back to Bruce Banner for those
two years when Thor finally gets him to
come back to banner he freaks out
stating that if he turns back into the
Hulk again he may never be able to come
back to being Bruce Banner but in the
final fight scene Bruce realizes that he
has to turn into the Hulk to help Thor
and save Asgard as you can see here we
still have the Hulk he hasn't turned
back to Bruce Banner yet which leads us
to the after the credits scene in Thor
Ragnarok where Thanos has ship arrives
fair warning
from here we're going to be talking
about some theories that may contain
some spoilers of what may happen in
Avengers infinity war you may have heard
some theories that the Hulk and Bruce
Banner are terrified of fan o's this is
actually confirmed by Mark Ruffalo
himself in an interview he did with
comic book calm in the interview he
states and I quote Banner knows probably
more about Thanos than anybody he's
really trying to impress on everybody
how dangerous he is it's a little bit of
Chicken Little
he comes in screaming bloody murder he
sees what damage Thanos can cause and
how powerful he is
unquote so what exactly is Ruffalo
talking about here he's talking about
the end of Thor Ragnarok where Thanos a
ship comes upon Thor ships that has Thor
and the Hulk on it along with all the
survivors of Asgard
what will most likely happen is that
Thanos will board the ship looking for
the space stone which is the tesseract
right now and Thor the Hulk and all the
remaining fighters will try to stop him
this clearly does not end well for them
as we've seen in the trailers we see
Loki standing over multiple dead bodies
as he hands the tesseract of Thanos we
also know that the guardians of the
galaxy pick up Thor from mid space and
we also know that the Hulk ends up back
on earth and the sanctum sanctorum with
Doctor Strange and Wong this is where
the Hulk and dr. banner begin to freak
out becoming Chicken Little
they've just seen what Thanos can do and
might I add he probably didn't have any
of the Infinity stones yet maybe he had
the ether that he could have gotten from
the collector at this point but even
then that's still just one Infinity
stone so they are freaking out because
they have no idea what kind of power he
can do with six Infinity stones this is
why banner is freaking out not only
because he just witnessed Thanos his
power but also because he's afraid to
turn back into the Hulk again this ties
into other theories that it's actually
banner piloting the Hulkbuster Iron Man
suit and not Iron Man himself the logic
beam that banner is afraid of turning
back into the Hulk because he doesn't
think he'll be able to become banner
again so stark lets him use the
Hulkbuster suit because he can pilot it
as banner then when the Hulkbuster suit
gets overtaken during battle against
Stannis's army banner turns into the
Hulk again busting out of the Hulkbuster
suit he then will fight as the Hulk
throughout the remainder of the movie
we've also seen a picture of a toy that
is supposed to be released of the
Hulkbuster suit that has a picture of
the Hulk inside the suit this could
however just be something to derail us
from knowing too much Marvel and the
Russo brothers have been known to do
this the Russo brothers put out a
picture on Instagram of Thor's mighty
hammer Mjolnir when we know that
infinity war Thor will actually be using
Stormbreaker
what do you think about these theories
and what do you think will happen with
the Hulk and Avengers infinity war let
me know in the comments below and don't
forget to drop a like and please
subscribe to my channel to stay
up-to-date on Avengers infinity war
Marvel and all things superhero thank
you so much for watching and have a
great day